cardi B and Megan D stallion advise
women to ask for car while having sex
with a man what kind of mindset does
this create for young impressionable
Minds my first recommendation for
parents is no earbuds no headsets you
need to know what your kids are
listening to hurting me making the
stallion the song you're referring to As
Weapons of seeing and it is meant to be
obscene parents need to be aware that
American popular culture not all of it
but much of it now is really toxic and
is promoting a view of man and woman
that really is harmful and leads to
anxiety and depression you don't see a
lot of people in your position they kind
of just go with the flow kind of scared
to speak out against these things Bruno
Mars you talk about him winning six
Grammys for his song that's what I like
in which he offered a woman gold jewelry
if she just turned around and drop it
for a player every one worked up you
know everyone's worked up over Andrew
Tate why is nobody going after Bruno
bars for exploiting women like this